voilà bonjour chars leurs objectifs
aujourd'hui j'ai là l'occasion la
possibilité de discuter avec charlène
[Musique]
qui parle qui est donc quadrilingue
c'est l'expression c'est sympa le
français l'espagnol l'anglais le
japonais
voilà qui a déchaîné youtube qui
s'appelle on sent que là-bas tout à fait
bon est d'abord première question
comment ça se fait que vous parlez 4
alors pour moi déjà je suis française ma
langue maternelle selle français et
pendant toute ma scolarité forcément en
france j'ai appris l'anglais comme comme
tout le monde mais j'avais très envie de
pousser un peu l'apprentissage parce que
pour moi c'était pas assez donc j'étais
toujours à la recherche de contenus
intéressants je traduisais des chansons
quand j'étais petite faim j'étais
vraiment dans l'apprentissage de la
langue
oui et du coup quand j'ai eu 18 ans je
voulais apprendre une autre langue et je
suis parti en espagne à barcelone là où
je suis actuellement et je suis parti en
espagne sans savoir vraiment parler
espagnol parce que je n'avais absolument
pas étudié la langue
j'ai appris sur le tas vraiment ici dans
la rue comme on peut dire et ensuite je
suis restée pendant huit ans et ensuite
je suis parti au japon pendant presque
trois ans et demi pour travailler en
tant que professeur est pareil je
connaissais absolument rien de la langue
tout pratiquement d'un fan le japonais
l'espagnol en tout cas l'élan que j'ai
apprise un petit peu en tant qu'adulte
ce sont des langues que j'ai apprise
dans le pays sans être allé à des cours
de langue
dans le pays même donc c'est pour ça que
je parle si quatre langues
voilà bon mais bon dans le cas de
l'espagnol très loin du français non ses
tresses est très proche c'est vrai mais
quand même
donc c'est une question quoi de deux
heures de rencontrer des gens d'un dans
la rue quand resteront dans des magasins
ou est-ce qu'il ya quand même des des
voyages les activités même sans aller
des courts et longs métrages
vous avez fait des choses spécifiques
quelle était la stratégie pour
l'apprentissage d'abord de l'espagnol
puis ensuite déjà près d'accord alors
stratégie je sais pas si on peut
l'appeler stratégie parce qu'à ce moment
là je n'avais aucune mais oui j'ai
essayé de rencontrer vraiment beaucoup
d'hispanophones beaucoup beaucoup je
vivais avec une famille qui était moitié
suisse moitié espagnol mais qui parlait
beaucoup français à la maison donc ce
n'était pas vraiment l'endroit où
j'allais apprendre beaucoup mais c'est
vrai que j'ai connu pas mal d'espagnol
donc j'ai appris pas mal à ce moment là
j'ai eu un petit copain espagnol chose
qui aide énormément
il faut dire ce qui est du coup du coup
oui j'ai beaucoup appris l'espagnol
vraiment comme ça
en écoutant et en imitant finalement
j'ai fait quand même comme quand j'étais
enfant finalement limité et j'ai parlé
ensuite j'ai appris l'espagnol à
l'université et de la grammaire la
phonétique l'inde tout et c'est là où
j'ai perfectionné disons le niveau est
ce que vous aurez beaucoup de lui ouais
je lisais pas mal je lisais pas mal
c'est ce que je dis j'ai pas mal je
lisais beaucoup d'articles d'articles de
presse même si je comprenais pas
exactement les 100% du de l'article
n'était pas grave pour moi c'était
important de rester un petit peu restez
connectés et donc oui je lisais pas mal
d'articles est ce que je faisais c'est
que j'aime beaucoup la musique donc j'ai
toujours été très intéressée par les
paroles de chansons et donc je lisais
les paroles de chansons que j'écoutais
et ça m'a permis en fait d'apprendre
beaucoup beaucoup de mots
en espagnol à ce moment là est ce que
vous regardiez la télévision ouais aussi
c'est vrai c'est vrai ce moment là c'est
vrai qu'à ce moment là je regardais pas
mal la télé et c'est vrai que ça ça m'a
beaucoup aidé c'est vrai ouais c'est
vrai ça a été beaucoup de foot
oui c'est vrai que maintenant que je me
souviens il ya très longtemps il ya plus
de 15 ans de ça mais c'est vrai que
maintenant je me souviens j'avais
beaucoup l'espagnol constamment dans les
oreilles dont je vivais à barcelone ont
forcément c'était facile en dix 10 ans
mais c'est avec we j'écoutais beaucoup
la radio la la radio - part dans la télé
je lisais aussi des journaux je lisais
les paroles de chansons j'étais assez je
voulais une immerger un petit peu dans
la culture c'est vrai oui c'est bien
dans mon corps aussi par exemple j'ai
quand j'étais étudiant change voyager à
des milliers des millions de m waouh je
parlais tout en parler tout en un avec
un jour près du rond la cisr parler ça
aide énormément
même si on se trompe car on apprend oui
mais en allant du français à l'espagnol
c'est facile ouais c'est maintenant
comment ça s'est passé avec le japonais
avec le japonais
moi je suis arrivé je disais à osaka et
à osaka
je suis arrivé vraiment sans savoir
enfin je parlais trois jeudi et trois
mots quoi j'avais été un petit une
petite introduction dans une école juste
pour apprendre rapidement quelques mots
c'était peut-être 15h02 japonais donc
c'était vraiment rien et je suis arrivé
je cherche du travail de directement
j'en ai eu
j'avais pas vraiment besoin de japonais
dans mon travail donc ça a été un
apprentissage assez chaotique lent je
vais dire mais efficace parce qu'après
quelques quelque temps j'étais j'étais
complètement capable d'avoir des
discussions avec des gens bien sûr que
mon niveau 2 g n est pas parfait ça
c'est sûr je le sais il est pas
oui mais pas parfait mais la
communication est possible et pour moi
la finalité d'une langue c'est vraiment
la communication donc même si je fais
des fautes c'est pas grave je sais qu'on
me comprends et je sais que je peux
peaufiner ça je l'a pas actuellement je
prends des cours de japonais en ligne
une fois par semaine et sam sam ça
m'amène ça me ça m'amène à me poser des
questions et ça me et ça m'aide beaucoup
en fait à à peaufiner ma grand mère et
je regrette un peu de ne pas l'avoir
fait plus tôt finalement mais ouais
ouais ok et maintenant quelle est votre
activité va tâter notre chaîne a lieu du
web et vous enseigner oui alors il
ajouté oui je suis je suis professeur de
français en ligne donc j'enseigne le
français est aussi l'espagnol en ligne
j'ai un site internet qui s'appelle
bonjour bcn point comme sur lequel ge
explique un petit peu ce que je fais et
donc c'est mon activité principale je
suis enseignante en vignes depuis
barcelone héritera tous les détails d'un
ouais dans la barre d'infos toujours à
barreaux oui et elle à l'enseignement
une des questions là que voilà pour moi
dans l'apprentissage l'apprentissage et
le contenu comme qu'on utilise parce que
bon je ne suis pas au japon je ne suis
pas à l'espagne
souvent les personnes apparaît personnes
sont chez eux dans un pays on ne parle
pas la langue qu'ils sont en train
d'apprendre
donc le contenu et ça devient très
important le contenu qu'on peut écouter
quand on peut par la suite lire souvent
des choses qu'on peut utiliser sur les
rails et ya des langues comme le
français l'espagnol ya beaucoup de
contenus sur l'internet il yad'autres
l'emmenant mois mais souvent il y a donc
de vous du contenu pour les débutants il
a beaucoup il ya peu trop même
ouais ouais il était le contenu
difficile donc authentique basse et s
est sans limite
parce que ça il ya des livres il ya des
toute altération grandiose n'importe
quoi mais souvent c'est là c'est le
niveau intermédiaire qui manquent pour
permettre aux gens d'aller des choses
qui sont devenus confortable parce que
c'est facile parce qu'ici ils l'ont déjà
fait et puis le vrai l'authentiqué trop
difficile et ceux qui vivent c'est ce
qu'il ya entre les deux et c'est là j'ai
même interview est bon le français
authentiques il ya rien qu'à quelques
entrepreneurs disent on donnera pas plus
de noms mais je les ai interviewé et qui
ont créé les choses entre les deux oui
et précédemment est ce que vous utilisez
à quelles ressources vous utilisez gras
pour aider pour pour moi dans mon
travail
oui d'accord alors ça dépend du niveau
bien sûr les sillons pas de
l'intermédiaire j'utilise beaucoup de
documents authentiques donc on a en
ligne parce que oui je pense que vous
avez raison dans le sens où il ya
beaucoup de choses pour débutants mais
aussi beaucoup de choses pour pour des
avancées pour des niveaux avancés et peu
pour des niveaux intermédiaires mais
quelquefois en fait je pense qu'il faut
aussi mettre un peu à des filles l'élève
et le maître devant des choses un peu un
peu compliqué parce que s'il reste tout
le temps devant des choses trop depuis
trop facile ou de débutants l'élève a
tendance un petit peu à rester un peu
comment d'y rester un peu ouais à se
reposer un peu sur ses lauriers on
dirait en français et du coup je pense
que c'est important tout en
l'accompagnant avec beaucoup de
bienveillance et on est en pro près de
lui en lui disant que s'il ya quelque
chose qui va pas forcément on va l'aider
je pense que c'est aussi important de le
mettre un certain niveau à partir d'un
certain niveau de le mettre devant des
choses un petit peu compliqué des défis
non des jeux vidéo comme un challenge
finalement ça ce que je lis tous les
jours
oui excusez moi un mur dont tu dis
toujours à mes élèves que par exemple
jugé les groupes mois d'espagnol deux
fois par une fois par semaine et
quelquefois les élèves ne comprennent
pas un mot ou deux mots où ils me disent
ah là tu parles un peu vite ou là je te
comprends pas et chaque fois je leur dit
ne vous inquiétez pas ne vous inquiétez
pas vous allez comprendre sûrement à la
prochaine la prochaine semaine ou dans
deux semaines ou dans trois semaines si
vous ne comprenez pas ce mois-ci vous
allez comprendre le mois prochain
c'est de l'immersion totale il faut
s'immerger un petit peu dans la langue
moi quand je suis arrivée au japon je ne
comprenais absolument rien et petit à
petit j'ai cliqué les faits les
connexions je me suis à mais ça ça
voulait dire ça et ça en fait c'est dans
ce contexte là que je vais l'utiliser
j'ai fait un petit peu les connexions
comme un enfant ferait quand il est
comme s'il apprend sa langue maternelle
c'est un tout petit peu différent parce
que le cerveau à ce stade là est
différent mais en tout cas je pense que
c'est important d'utiliser des choses
quelquefois d'un niveau un peu supérieur
pour motiver les élèves
je pense à prévoit la justice beaucoup
de ressources y avait des ressources
aussi que j'utilise que je fais moi même
mais oui je pense qu'en documents
authentiques c'est tout à fait tout à
fait possible en tout cas pour pour des
intermédiaires
oui je suis d'accord aussi d'accord avec
vous que le fait de ne pas compenser pas
grave c'est pas grave quand en forêt
défense et de l'immersion le fait que ça
que tu as fait de la langue entre bon il
ya des choses tout à fait que c'est
quand même le fait de faire des erreurs
il faut pas chercher la perfection et
c'est pour ça que tu as i contre les
questions de coopération
je déteste j'ai compris ce que j'ai
compris j'ai mal compris je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est vrai quand
jacques ange enseigné le français au
japon a des petits ils avaient entre 3
et 8 9 ans on avait des classes
d'immersion totale pendant cinq heures
d'affilée un tous les jours et au début
les enfants trois ans et qu'on prenait
absolument rien du tout et en fait c'est
incroyable et merveilleux de voir comme
le l'enfant au bout de quelques semaines
il commence déjà à capter quelque chose
à bien ok là il est 10 heures elle m'a
dit d'aller aux toilettes
ok je capte que deezer il faut aller aux
toilettes toilettes ça veut dire ça et
c'était super c
c'est incroyable le cerveau il est
incroyable et je pense que l'adulte est
capable de oddo cie faire ça donc moi je
parle beaucoup beaucoup la langue dans
ma dans mes cours si c'est les cours de
français je ne parle que français c'est
des cours d'espagnol je ne parle que
l'espagnol est bien sûr j'adapte à je
vais pas parler comme un natif j'accepte
bien sûr mais je crois vraiment en je
crois vraiment que que l'immersion
totale et le fait d'être un peu perdu
quelquefois ça aide c'est l'élève oui je
suis d'accord et la quantité de contenu
qu'il faut consommer
non ces photos ni mon côté c'est
illimité mais quand le roi de libye
parmi eux mêmes le système similaire par
le temps moi je ne trouve rien je le
recommande pas personnellement non non
mais ils disent avec je livre là vous
allez atteindre un niveau b2 nantes
angers qui fera pas faux l'info il faut
champ lire jeu on a des statistiques à
lire je sais combien de millions de mont
joli en russe combien de milliers de
l'or que j'ai écouté il voit tellement
de contenu pour que le cerveau apprend
quand vous avez dit le cerveau ne fait
qu ne peut faire que à prendre
exactement faut beaucoup beaucoup de
potes pour que ce quart est donc
complètement ses infinies et c'est super
intéressant vraiment super avec
maintenant les podcasts qui a laissé un
incroyable en tous cas tout ce qu'on
peut écouter tous les jours mais
malheureusement souvent les podcasts ils
n'ont pas de train de transcrit ans que
ça c'est ouais ça c'est vrai que c'est
un peu là c'est vrai c'est dommage
c'est dommage c'est vrai moi ok voilà et
et en espagnol et catalan le catalan dès
lors si l'enveloppé renoleau no love
l'algérie à celle opposant tender
correctement départ quelques larmes
mucho tiempo vivaki père au chômage
castillane aller à ses attentes
ok si c'est la bonne décision importante
est arrivé à qui ce super importante et
ses six préfaces il savait ce par un
honneur personnel français ça se
bastonne d'effacer la première le
parquet séparer salle princesse anne
espagnols ainsi qu'un italien ordos non
c'est en ces temps ci alors si tu as
nancy s'est soucié croient que leur
total matin si si c'est exact c'est
pratique et la cftc elle rappelé
difficile
clara clara clara sur les toits de paris
n'a personne à qena au second poteau
d'après la police n'utilise ni mona
référence ian schultz et les robes
qu'elles ont français s'y connaissait en
sciences ces caisses pas facile si j si
la ligue l'as saint etienne voilà bien
que séparés sont évidemment voilà déjà
quinze minutes ça passe vite
s'il ya une chose est sûre intéressante
n'est ce pas merci beaucoup à l'époque
voilà merci beaucoup estiment salut
salut
[Musique]